ich hatte schon der wind gehabt als
bürgermeisterin werde ich immer wieder
angesprochen
das sieht man die politik die gerade ist
dass man das nicht versteht dass
viel gesprochen wird aber nicht an kommt
bei den menschen und da fragt man sich
schon wie weit entfernt hat sich denn
die politik von den menschen und ich bin
mir sicher dass auch mit dem dritten
entlastungspaket alle wollen das beste
für den menschen aber vergessen dabei
dass so kommunikativ rüberzubringen dass
es verstehen was da eigentlich passiert
und so verlieren wir die menschen und da
sollten wir für fall aufpassen dass wir
einfach direkt und schnell und
kommunikativ sind frau wagenknecht wie
sehr verlieren wie denn die menschen was
merken sie dann auch weil sich wenn sie
mit den bürgern sprechen sie bekommen ja
auch viele zuschriften ja ich will
kommen sehr viel und ich glaube es ist
nicht nur ein kommunikationsproblem also
auch klar politik bewegt sich oft in der
blase wenn man nicht aktiv etwas dagegen
tut weil ein politiker ist natürlich
privilegiert er lebt in einer anderen
welt und wenn menschen das spüren also
wenn zb mal eben so getan wird ja also
wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen uns also
unser wohlstand etwas reduzieren da klar
also für minister auch wenn abgeordnete
kann seinen wohlstand reduzieren aber
doch nicht jemanden alleinerziehende
mutter die so schon nicht überboten
monat kommt oder eine rentnerin mit
einer niedrigen rente oder auch ein
familienvater der jeden abend viel zu
spät nach hause kommt und kaum zeit für
seine familie hat damit ja irgendwie die
ernähren kann also die können nicht in
wohlstand reduzieren weil sie schon nur
ein gescheiter haben politiker jemals
näher bei den leuten
ich würde schon sagen dass sich da einer
bundesrepublik was verändert hat ja also
wir sehen es ja auch daran es war ja
meine viel höhere wahlbeteiligung als
die leute haben ja auch das gefühl
gehabt offenbar dass sie mehr verstanden
werden und wir haben schon eine immer
stärkere einflussnahme auch großer
unternehmen auf die politik nicht der
klaren sicht des mittelstands aber
großer konzerne mit ihren lobbyisten wie
immer stärker auch die gesetze machen
wir hatten das vor der finanzkrise einer
reitschule steigt die einflussnahme der
unternehmen die these von frau
wagenknecht
das ist schwer zu messen ob das
einsteigt oder ob aufs feld die der der
einfluss war immer da man kann ja nicht
als eine der größten wirtschaftsnationen
der welt in der politik machen die quasi
an der wirtschaft vorbei geht um die
großen unternehmen es geht nicht um die
die mittleren und ja aber anja er aber
schon die aber deutschland hat ja immer
politik im sinne der autoindustrie
beispielsweise gemacht oder des
maschinenbaus die interessen zu
vertreten ist ja legitim die frage ist
ob illegitim einfluss genommen wird
zugunsten einer branche die dann sich
vorteile verschafft oder im
internationalen wettbewerb wenn man sich
anguckt was die franzosen innerhalb der
europäischen union mit ihrer agrar
sparte machen das ist auch nicht ganz
sauber und ordnungspolitisch auch nicht
ganz in ordnung also es ist so weit okay
wie wir interessen unseres landes
vertreten und nicht monopole schaffen
nicht einzelnen leuten etwas zu
schustern das ist schon völlig in
ordnung das andere problem was wir in
der tat haben ist dass die
kommunikationswege so viel vielfältiger
geworden sind heutzutage dass auch
politiker einfach mehr arbeit bei der
kommunikation zukommt und das haben
viele nicht begriffen ich kriege aus der
unionsfraktion täglich ein mehrere
dutzend pressemitteilung die fleißige
hände dort tapfer jeden tag verschicken
die
in 90 prozent der redaktionen sofort
gelöscht werden weil seine e mail fächer
verstopfen kein mensch druck
pressemitteilung ab das ist das hat mit
kommunikation nichts zu tun und
rausgehen meinetwegen können die sich
sparen das können sie sich sparen das
ist aber vielleicht auch einen
arbeitsnachweis für einzelne abgeordnete
die sprecher einer ag sind oder was das
kabel ist schade am ende auch nichts
das problem ist einfach dass viele
politiker noch nicht verstanden haben
dass kommunikation zu einer dauer
angelegenheit geworden ist und nicht nur
alle vier jahre mal den schirm vom
supermarkt aufstellen oder auf dem
offenen markt man sollte schon öfter da
sein weil sonst einfach die
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten so
vielfältig sind dass die leute sich dann
im netz informieren ganze milieus sich
das zusammenballen und sich die
informationen suchen die ihre ideen am
besten bestätigen und die sind auch dann
später nicht mehr rückholbar also man
muss eigentlich versuchen ständig
erreichbar zu sein ständig zu
kommunizieren gerne auch auf sozialen
medien das ist verdammt anstrengend
ruiniert mitunter auch die nerven man
kriegt ja nicht nur zuspruch aber anders
funktioniert es nicht wenn die leute
nicht das gefühl geben dass man
denn eigentlich noch möglich also als
bürgermeisterin sie jetzt nicht ganz so
groß wie man sich da so heißt es denn da
für sie noch möglich was eigentlich eine
schule gerade gefordert hat dass man
wirklich da ist und wirklich alles
beantworten finde das kann man fordern
also ich sehe es beim einen
bundestagsabgeordneten es ist sehr wohl
möglich der ist im sommer sechs sieben
acht wochen unterwegs lars klingbeil
richte er aus was die chefin von laska
weil ich seine kreisvorsitzende will
ich meine das jetzt im ernst der ist
wenn man also motto jedes ja ich hab das
schon seit 10 der ist da und jeden tag
gibt es eine runde wo leute dazukommen
können und zusätzlich dazu gibt es eine
telefonsprechstunde die zeit nimmt er
sich und er ist parteivorsitzender und
bundestagsabgeordneter das erwarte ich
auch irgendwie und das kann ich auch von
anderen abgeordneten erwarten und das
sehe ich leider nicht weil ein
abgeordneten die sich hier vermutlich
jetzt auch bei der spd und insbesondere
bei last klingen bei großen redebedarf
wenn er nämlich vor allem auch spd
wähler würde ich jetzt mal schätzen
natürlich auch angst haben mit blick auf
den winter absolut natürlich haben sie
angst und das merke ich halt immer in
sprechstunden auch dass die menschen
kommen und sagen wie ist denn das jetzt
mit dieser energiekosten den rentner
noch sehr hatten warum kriegen wir denn
eigentlich nicht studieren denn die mir
schreiben über instagram und sagen was
warum wohnen während vergessen dann
müssen wir das erklären und es wäre
einfacher wenn sich die abgeordneten
auch im bundestag sitzen diese politik
mittragen vor ort gehen in die kommunen
reingehen und ihre politik erkläre was
sagen sie denn wenn jemand sagt so warum
wurde ich denn jetzt vergesst nicht
meint olaf scholz ist ja ihr spd boss
kann man jetzt war salopp sagen was
sagen na ja also ich brauch nicht alles
schön zu reden das ist einfach so gerade
bei den rentnern studierenden so mein
kleiner bruder sehr was studierende ich
erlebt dass ja hautnah da ich auch ich
kann das nicht verstehen ich verstehe es
nicht so dass ich jetzt kann man sagen
ja ich weiß ja nicht ob christian
lindner das geld nicht ausgeben wollte
keine ahnung aber dafür müssten sich
auch nicht in berlin aber bei solchen
sachen muss man ehrlich sein und wenn
ich der meinung bin ich verstehe es auch
nicht ich habe dafür kein verständnis
warum rentnerin dann nicht dieser die
kostenpauschale bekommen sagt nur noch
studierende dann sage ich das auch
ehrlich und dann ist mir das eigentlich
auch egal dass olaf scholz spd kanzler
ist aber da muss man ehrlich sein und so
kann man die leute auch nicht an das
merken sie ja auch so dass heißt der
bundestag muss mehr arbeiten zumindest
müssen sie vor ort ihre leute mitnehmen
können und wenn wir das nicht machen
verlieren wir einfach und wir haben halt
so eine krisenzeit gerade und das 50
niemand und ich merke ja auch die leute
die die laufen und die wollen das beste
für den für die bürgerinnen bürger aber
es muss verständlich erklärt werden und
es muss vor ort darüber gebracht werden
vor gericht dass ich wahrscheinlich
dieselbe meinung ja also ich finde das
absolut richtig die forderung dass
politiker wirklich mit den bürgern reden
dass sie vor ort sind dass sie auch
veranstaltungen machen dass ich meine
das ist für mich auch ein lebenselixier
also diese direkte kommunikation
natürlich auch über social media klar
man kriegt ja auch ganz viele reaktionen
bei youtube bei instagram bei facebook
alles wichtig auch dass sie nicht nur in
ihrer babbel sind also das ist auch eine
gefahr also das sehe ich durchaus bei
politikern also die jetzt vor allem in
social media unterwegs sind da muss man
natürlich aufpassen man hat natürlich
meistens eine bestimmte blase und wenn
man zum beispiel twitter das was da
andere aktion kommt für die welt hält
dann kann da eine ziemlich schräge
politik raus kommen aber ich würde
trotzdem noch mal an meinem ursprungs
these anknüpfen also dass die politiker
vor ort sind dass sie mit den menschen
leben dass sie deren probleme überhaupt
kennen und wahrnehmen und wissen und
nicht irgendwie so daher reden alles
wichtig alles richtig aber eine gute
politik muss gut erklärt werden aber
eine schlechte politik da nützt es dann
auch nicht sie vor ort gut zu erklären
weil die leute trotzdem merken mir geht
es schlechter ich werde hier über den
tisch gezogen ich verliere wohlstand
oder ich habe kaum ein und jetzt werde
ich richtig arm gemacht also das ist
schon ein problem und wenn sie sagen die
politik ist nicht mehr abgehoben als
früher ja zum beispiel die
verflechtungen mit der wirtschaft die
haben ja deutlich zugenommen also diese
drehtüreffekt nur politiker macht einem
unternehmen einen großen gefallen und
wenn er dann nicht mehr aktiver
politiker ist dann wechselt er in genau
das unternehmen das er vorher begünstigt
hat das gab es früher in dieser form
nicht